ce qui ferait quand même savoir lever
les yeux au ciel et le voir poindre
entre les branches de ses grands chênes
une certaine image du printemps mais
pour ses spécialistes de la forêt un
signal parfois alarmant
des arbres qui perdent leurs feuillage
premier stigmate d'une saison trop
chaude
face au réchauffement climatique la
forêt est en grande souffrance
un chêne avant quand il a subi
climatiques comme on en a déjà connu
il se remettait et puis même si quand il
commençait à dépérir un chêne il mettait
4-5 voir 10 ans à décrocher et à
vraiment mourir donc on avait le temps
de le voir de se poser la question
laisse on ne laisse pas est-ce qu'on
doit le récolter mais là ce qu'on
observe maintenant c'est qu'on a des
chaînes qui en quelques mois vont
vraiment passer de vie à trépas pour
sauvegarder la forêt il est essentiel
pour ses experts d'anticiper et
d'adapter les plantations aujourd'hui il
faut vraiment procéder à une analyse
beaucoup plus fine peut-être de ce qu'on
faisait jusqu'à présent à la fois du sol
regardez aussi quelques quelles sont les
prévisions d'évolution climatique qu'on
peut avoir là on a par exemple le chêne
Cécile vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui il est
bien adapté dans la région mais par
contre compte tenu du changement qu'on
nous prédit on voit que il y a une bonne
partie de la région dans lequel il
souffrir dans les d'ici 45 ans alors la
durée de vie d'un chêne elle est
supérieure à 50 ans parmi les solutions
faire venir des essences d'arbres plus
résistantes à la chaleur on essaye de
faire un trou d'introduire des
provenances plus sudistes du chêne
Cécile du chêne pédonculé c'est-à-dire
des chaînes coma on va aller chercher au
sud de la France voir au-delà mais on va
les chercher aussi des chaînes carrément
méditerranéens du chêne pubes du chêne
Tauzin diagnostic et solutions sont au
cœur des travaux de la coopérative
forestière unie Silva en Centre-Val de
Loire elle regroupe plus de 3500
propriétaires forestiers préoccupés par
le réchauffement climatique ils en
inquiète ici intéressent et ils
demandent alors coopérative de faire les
éléments de réfléchir à comment conduire
leur peuplement pour non seulement
éviter d'avoir des grosses pertes dessus
mais les adapter pour les années à venir
et ça dépasse la capacité d'une personne
toute seule qui n'est pas dedans toute
la journée puis d'une centaine de
propriétaires s'est déplacés aujourd'hui
dans cette forêt du Loir-et-Cher tous
constatent les effets de la sécheresse
on voit des jeunes arbres qui meurent
comme ça on se dit bizarre
mais on va bientôt trouver une solution
madame moi je suis plein d'optimisme sur
le sur l'évolution un optimisme nourrit
par l'espoir de transmettre l'amour de
la forêt aux jeunes générations une
certaine religion je veux dire à
inculqué aux enfants et aux petits
enfants et on voudrait que tous la garde
un message clé pour préserver l'avenir
des forêts en Centre-Val de Loire elle
représente plus d'un quart du territoire